welcome to this video playing Glen
quagmire and quagmire
hmm well sure I should know what this
means
probably some reference um okay we have
a French winner and he played Bishop d3
it's not a very common response it's
just plain plain normal moves getting
pressure on the center ok 95 maybe Oh is
this
it's just losing too much time check
maybe this one getting some play on the
light squares sorry
hmm it's also easy to develop maybe
queen 85 rook the end yeah yeah I
thought if five would be okay I want to
get this control over fo in de for a
pawn down of course but shouldn't be a
big problem okay 94 traits the bishops
make sure that I mean you can take on c6
as possible but this triple pawn is
going nowhere no way are them and taking
on g4 that looks very nice for black
interesting interesting reply I can take
you for but then it takes here yeah okay
Jeff okay I want to go to u7 quickly
yeah that's one problem of this
structure this always be 7-under and the
fire
and he might have rook g7 picking up the
H pawn Knight e5 this route b5
yeah it's difficult really I can maybe
get enough counterplay here but it's not
very attractive and of course I can look
before oh that's bad I wanted to go 94
and then get back the sit bone
check yeah yes they each born of course
hmm
yeah yeah I still I need to get some of
the material back okay
maybe check Jake's and then behind the
poem
okay
if he goes h5 I think I can go look at
these 60 and with my upon the opponent
is more dangerous than the age upon
check
it's just promoting what the heck am I
doing here oh I want the AIDS not only
7000 stupid can you be
oh okay black resigns what dick
okay unbelievable
I just totally totally blundered this
there's nothing special going on here
check can also play this or whatever
it's just a look and game I don't know I
don't know it should be should be
playable yeah I got into I got into
trouble out of the opening him here I
should have thought a bit more here
maybe this I don't I don't know in
retrospect if this is any good
maybe it should be six intending 55 I
don't know
check yeah maybe this isn't I mean the
compass on 0.2 where it's not like I'm
losing here but it's it's very difficult
to do anything I mean in terms of in
terms of forward you know I can't go
King I can go Luke age 18 you know maybe
I should have done that simply keeping
the keeping the pawn I really want to
play such a passive but I have King e6
and maybe get the rook out yeah that's
better
I then just blended oh okay thanks for
watching